alors derniers éléments de ce dossier le
président de la république vous venez de
l'entendre ayant lui-même déclaré en
suisse que cette situation était
intolérable que compte faire le
gouvernement français c'est la question
que nous avons posée ce matin à monsieur
max gallo porte parole du gouvernement
que nous allons entendre interrogé donc
ce matin monsieur galles le problème ne
peut pas être réglé uniquement au plan
national et c'est pourquoi le 16 juin de
cette année à la réunion qui se tiendra
à luxembourg des ministres de
l'environnement de la communauté
européenne la france est décidée à
ouvrir ce dossier à ouvrir ce dossier
qui est ouvert pratiquement par cette
affaire et notamment à proposer ce qui
est déjà sa réglementation à ce que les
producteurs les producteurs ici
hoffmann-la roche soit responsable
deux des déchets des produits qu'ils
fabriquent et ne se dissimule pas
derrière une chaîne plus ou moins
obscurs et toujours discrète de sous
traitants
je crois que c'est cela qui est en
question avec cette affaire il s'est
toujours pas sonné déchets c'est vrai
c'est vrai mais là écoutez on se heurte
à je dirai au refus de monsieur par 1 go
je crois que la justice est saisie et le
dossier est entre ses mains
est-ce que vous avez des éléments qui
sont dans ce dossier les éléments oui
nous savons que les flux ont circulé en
france qu'ils sont arrivés jusqu'à saint
quentin qu'ils ont été dédouanés là et à
partir de là le ministère de
l'environnement a agi immédiatement et
je dois dire que la presse aussi a fait
son travail et que c'est en somme le
résultat d'une collaboration heureuse
entre l'opinion publique et d'autre part
le gouvernement clamant à son heureuse
qui pour le moment ne débouche sur rien
écoutez on ne peut pas résoudre
miraculeusement un problème ce que je
veux marquer de manière très précise
c'est que dans cette affaire il y a deux
éléments 3 à dire est d'abord un élément
de fond c'est que le problème devait
être réglé à l'échelon européen et nous
le ferons
le 16 juin deuxièmement que le
gouvernement français a agi de manière
énergique et rapide et troisièmement que
je peux le dire très calmement le
gouvernement français a agi d'une
manière beaucoup plus efficace et
beaucoup plus énergique que les autres
gouvernements européens